happy New Year and welcome to the agenda
let's take a look at what's happening
next week in Strasbourg at the first
plenary of the month kelly mira a
leather as it takes over the presidency
of the council from lithuania but can
grease still in the throes of a six-year
recession with national debt a hundred
sixty nine point one percent i was gdp
really be a driving force for Europe's
economic recovery on the same day as any
Peas discussed the priorities of the new
presidency also look out for a public
hearing with Klaus wriggling the boss of
the European Stability Mechanism good
years economic problems be solved by
modernization of public procurement
rules the practice are contracting out
public goods and services to third
parties accounts of a nineteen percent
of EU GDP three reports face the music
at the plenary the hope is that clearer
rules could bring about more innovation
drive up growth in jobs and importantly
get more SMS on board the plastic
industry makes every three hundred
billion years a year but it also makes a
mountain of rubbish just one plastic
bottle like this can take over a hundred
years to biodegrade some say even
thousands of years on Tuesday em ups
will vote on new laws to better manage
plastic waste one of the big proposals
is to reduce waste by eighty percent by
2020 safe harbor is a joint agreement
between the EU and the US to ensure that
EU data is protected but in light of NSA
hacking route the agreement is on shaky
ground preliminary conclusions of
parliament civil liberties inquiry into
the hacking scandal say it's got to go
the water all institutions really think
find out on a joint declaration by the
council Commission and Parliament is
made at the phone airy and that's all we
have this agenda take care and enjoy the
week